okay the next the next method we're
going to discuss is k-means clustering
also a very useful tool for finding
clusters in the data and it works in any
dimension
but
in order to demonstrate it for you i'm
going to do it in two dimensions because
we can actually look at the clusters and
see how well it's done
so first what we're going to do is we
act here we can actually make some fake
data just for purposes of demonstration
so this is a typical incantation when
you make fake data so first of all we
set the seed the random number seed to
some using some arbitrary number 101
somehow is my arbitrary number it comes
up a lot so i set the seed
then i'm going to make a matrix of
random normals a two column matrix and i
want a hundred observations so i'll make
i i
embed it inside the quarter matrix the
data comes from r norm and i'm going to
make a hundred times two because i want
two columns standard normals
and then this says there's a hundred
columns and sorry 100 rows and two
columns okay so i generate the data
so at this point it's just a cloud of
gaussians
but now what i'm going to do is i'm
going to make four clusters so i'm going
to generate some means
and i'm going to displace some of these
gaussians by shifting their means around
and differently for each you know for
four clusters so the way i do that i
make another random normal matrix in
this case i want eight because there's
going to be four clusters each with two
means okay so i'm generating the means
here and here the random normals have
standard deviation four because i want
these means to be shift around much more
than the actual data did and so it's
going to be a four column matrix of
means and sorry four rows and two
columns
okay so that's how i get the means
and now i decide which of the rows get
which means so i'm going to
pick a random sample from the numbers
one to four i want a hundred of them
because i've got a hundred rows
and replace equals true so which is
going to say which observation belongs
to which cluster
so now simply add the appropriate mean
to the appropriate rows
so this is a this is a kind of typical r
vector operation that's nice and tricky
and and effective
so x mean is a four row matrix but i'm
indexing it with a hundred indices so
that'll produce a hundred row matrix
with two columns right so it'll pick out
the right the right mean for each row
and i just add it to the original x
okay and now make a plot
and there you have it so there's a plot
x so plots the first two chord they only
are two coordinates and
and i give it the color which is i give
it which which is
for each point is a number one to four
and it tells it which cluster it belongs
to
and uh and it just uses the colors one
two four which are black
uh red green and blue and so these are
the data and there we see the clusters
that i've imposed so we know the
clusters but now we're going to hand
these data to hierarchical clustering
and not tell it
what the clusters are and it's supposed
to find them automatically and we'll use
the k-means algorithm
okay we're going to tell it therefore
clusters yet
if we told there were three classes we
would probably find two of the clusters
and and then merge two of them together
okay so here we go we call k means
and we tell it four clusters and we tell
it to do
15 random starts random starts are cheap
if you remember
k means clustering starts with a random
start for where the clusters are and of
course if you pick a bad random start it
might find you a bad solution
unlikely in this case but that's what we
do anyway
and
we can print out the the result
and it prints out
a number of things for you
it prints out the cluster means there's
going to be four of them because they're
four clusters
the cluster vector
that's the assignment of each point to
the cluster that's clusters that it
found
and then there's some summaries of the
cluster this so the within cluster sum
of squares by cluster they're four
clusters so that's the sum of squares
within each cluster that sum of squares
deviations of each point around its
cluster mean
and then and this is perhaps more
interesting the between sum of squares
to the total sum of squares so this is
in a sense this is like the r squared
for clustering it's a percent of
variance explained by the cluster means
and that's pretty high so it suggests
it's done a good job
and then it tells us what the
the
other components on the cluster object
are
okay so now we're going to pla plot the
data
and there it is and
we've identified
the clusters that it found so we plot
the data with big circles
for each point
and the coloring year is not our
original cluster
when we generated the data we we
we made clusters this is the these are
the cluster assignments found by the
k-means clustering algorithm
so to see how well it did with in terms
of the original known clusters we can
include those points that's how i made
these circles a bit bigger so i put the
points inside
and well
what you see now is that we have a color
mismatch
so
we named we named the clusters one to
four in some order the k-means
clustering algorithm found four clusters
and it named them one two four but of
course the ordering is arbitrary so it
picked a different order
so we can look at the clusters here and
and just reassign the colors which is
what i do in the next line
and now you see
this is a more useful plot so we see
the outer circles are the k-means
clustering cluster id
and the inner points are our original
cluster id and you can see the
mismatches so there's a black point
which actually belonged to this cluster
from the original data was
assigned to the green cluster here
and there's a blue point that originally
belonged to this cluster has been
assigned to the black point quite
reasonably of course because it's much
closer to these as it turned out than
than not
so that's that's k means clustering for
you and just some nice graphical
techniques for um
for
for having a look at the
at the results if it's especially if the
data is in two-dimensional that's easy
to do